Frank Castle got something I need to show
I saw the video files the US military turns you into a hit-man Frank
Castle it's the last witness we can either clean this up or let them take us down. We'll need to see the truth
Hey, everybody Punisher is dropping this Friday. This is gonna be my non-spoilery review of the series so far
They've only released the first half of the season to critics so obviously there's a bunch of plot lines that they set up a bunch
of different characters that have arcs to sort of weave and
Intersect throughout the season that will all come together by the end or at least that's the idea the series works as well as you
Hope it will they'll all make sense together and the Punisher will find a solution for everything
So if you're just finding me for the first time be sure to subscribe to get everything
I'll be doing more easter-egg breakdowns as we get through the weekend just depending on how quickly
Everybody gets through episodes sometimes people take a little bit longer like usually people
Burn through daredevil a little bit faster than series like Jessica Jones or Luke Cage
but I'll also try to place this in the
Context of those other series it sort of ranked my favorite Netflix marble seasons
And I know there's a lot of talk about maybe Disney pulling all of the Netflix
Content regardless of what they do in future seasons there will be more seasons of these shows
So don't worry about that but leading the cast you have Jon Bernthal who does a?
master performance of the character best version of the characters so far
Even after a daredevil season 2 you would have said he's probably one of the best versions of the character
But whereas he's more of a backup character
You only see a little bit of him during daredevil season 2 you get like the full
Enchilada you get the backstory they sort of updated it for a modern context if you read him in the comics
You know he's a Vietnam vet now
He's a veteran of the war in Iraq and the war in Afghanistan and just a person having trouble dealing with civilian life
So post-traumatic stress survivor guilt those are big parts of his arc
You know about jigsaw you know about Rollins. You know about micro Karen Paige is the primary crossover character
There's a new character
That's not from the comics named Dinah
Madani who has this really big story arc that parallels a lot of the veterans
Story arcs like Frank Castle and the other people that he meets with he has a veteran support group that he goes to
Interacts with some other characters so that becomes part of his storyline
The series itself sort of like the big overarching themes take a really hard look at the military intelligence
industrial complex in the age of the war on terror because that's sort of when the wars took place that Frank was a part of
So it also takes a really hard look at the idea of these big governmental organizations taking really
Dissatisfied young people and turning them into killing machines and what happens to them when their government is done with them
But just sort of leaving them to dry. There's a conspiracy aspect to the show there's something. He's trying to uncover
Rollins is sort of the de facto kingpin villain type character for the series
And he was their commanding officer when they were in
Afghanistan they were a military
Unit like you've seen in the trailers that were forced to commit a lot of war crimes so part of the conspiracy
Storyline is them uncovering sort of the larger things at play where the Rollins characters hiding out committing all kinds of crimes against humanity
Wearing the badge of patriotism
Then as you have all that going on in the background you have Frank's
Internal journey as he deals with the loss of his family like obviously he's trying to get the people that killed his family
But he also himself did a lot of terrible things in Afghanistan
But the series tries to take a really intelligent stance on
Violence like the violence that he in acts as he's taking down even worse people doing bad things to take down even worse
People I think the message is is that he's never going to be absolved of the terrible things that he did
But he'll just become a much more balanced person. He'll be able to put it into perspective
So even though it's a big part of his character the series in no way condones violence
And that's where you basically get the jigsaw character because he says squadmate back in Afghanistan
So they have these parallel arcs where you know they both don't quite know how to fit back in now that there's civilians again
Jigsaw just fights that in a very different way from the Punisher the war that the Punisher is fighting is more like an internal war
In a war against domestic terror through the Rollins characters storyline and then sort of parallel to all that you have the Dynamo Donnie
Character who's at homeland security and the really interesting thing about her is that she's this Middle Eastern?
Character who is actually really good at her job
But because she's Middle Eastern people view her with this lens of suspicion because this is the age of the war on terror
So in the way that society doesn't really know what to do with veterans when they come back from a war
It's also the same thing with her character like they're not quite sure what to do with her inside Homeland Security even though
She's really good at her job
she's sort of the odd man out so to speak and the thing is is that obviously the Punisher does really terrible things so she
Learns about him and tries to take him down, but at the same time
She's tried to uncover the same conspiracy that Frank and Mike wrote together or trying to uncover
So I think the idea is is in the back half of the season she's probably going to find that she will need the Punisher
just as much as she thinks she needs to take him down so it's one of those push-pull things with law enforcement and
Vigilantes like you have the daredevil character the police can't officially sanction what Matt does at night?
But they need him because they can't do everything by themselves
But the interesting thing about the way the series picks up is because we haven't seen the Punisher since daredevil season 2 like he says
See you around red
There is a little bit of visual continuity with the way they shoot the first episode
so it feels very much like
Punisher during daredevil season 2 before the tone of the series changes just a little bit
And you get into core Punisher stuff so overall the first half of the season sets up some interesting plot lines
I think a lot of people are just hoping that they all connect by the end of the series
And I think most of the people I've seen complaining about it are mostly complaining about the more violent aspects of the show especially
Given the context of what's been happening in real life in the last couple of months
Like they push the release just a little bit because of a couple very public buried tragic shootings
But like I said the series actually does take a very intelligent
Stance on the idea of violence and the reason why the Punisher does the things that he does?
Probably one of the best characters besides the Punisher though is Mike Rowe
so like most people are thinking about Karen page because you know her from all the other series if
You know Mike Rowe from the comics this version is a little bit different albeit
He feels like he's right out of a Garth eNOS comic and obviously there's a lot of punisher max within this series
But it pulls from a bunch of different places so you punish a war general Punisher max Punisher proper
So you don't have to read any of the comics, but if you're big Garth eNOS fan
There's probably gonna be a lot more Easter eggs as we get through the series
But I think the series really does pick up once Punisher starts working with
Micro once they start bouncing off of each other because the Punisher character usually works best when he's a backup character
it's a little weird to see him take the forefront so that's why I
Think they're gonna try as hard as they can to use Frank in the other series going forward now
They haven't confirmed where he's gonna pop up after this season
But the thing that the Netflix series have been doing for the last couple of years
Is that it doesn't always do a new season every single year sometimes is every year and a half they probably won't drop that
Born-again Ark till this time next year my guess is is that he will pop back up during that because like he said
See you around read that see around part will probably be the born-again storyline next year
So what'll happen is is I'll talk about how the series is connected in more specific ways Easter eggs
And how they connect to the Marvel Universe when I start doing Easter Egg stuff this weekend?
So be sure to check it out all the episodes drop Thursday night midnight
Pacific time so in related news the Justice League premiere is today is I'm posting this video
So I'm supposed to be doing some special stuff for that
I'm not allowed to post my review for that till Wednesday night
So that's when that'll post but there'll be much more comic book stuff happening the flash
So just look at the top pin comment for the videos that are be coming next I'm still doing that
IMAX take a giveaway all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a comment on this video
I'll just announce the winner the next time I post a Marvel video so while you wait for everything you can click here for the
Last big punisher trailer and you can click here to learn all about the Thor Ragnarok deleted scenes and alternate post credits
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight